zombies are coming for us and they want
to eat our brains military may have its
own plan for what to do when the zombie
apocalypse comes because it will but
scientists have a different idea on how
to survive their tip head to the
mountains it would only take one day for
densely populated areas to fall to
zombies and months before zombies even
reach the northern mountain time zone so
maybe the gang on the walking dead had
the right idea to head to the mountains
in season one alright so I love the
story because it takes like my
post-apocalyptic zombie nightmare
scenario and I watch walking dead and
all that and then it combines a little
science scientists looked at this thing
so glad you know yeah you could maybe
survive a little bit longer if you were
in the rural areas well thank goodness
how long would it take you to be eaten
if a zombie apocalypse you're definitely
prepared have a very good I'm really
unprepared especially if I'm wearing
these shoes when it how that is that box
that will be pretty good for like a
stabbing in the eye that's true that's
true if I had any karate skills maybe I
I think maybe I'm more prepared than
Brynn was a couple months ago before you
got your lasik that's part of why you
got it oh yeah you got LASIK because if
I be fine I somebody told me you know
cuz I had I wore glasses before
sometimes and then somebody said that
you should get LASIK surgery in case
there's a zombie attack and you smash
the lasses him then you will be screwed
and so if I get LASIK now I don't have
to worry about having those glasses
because it'd be like I'd be that person
who like I / my glasses and then the
zombie later right so as I really
resonated with yeah that resonate so now
I have lasik and like I'm totally ready
and this office the riot office we can
do another show later on but it is built
as a fortress it's fortified I mean you
cannot I mean I'll get around it
discreetly zombie-proof from what i can
see yeah yeah yeah so just go to the
ride on the snacks too we live for about
two days don't start telling everybody
how many sex we have a porn where we are
what do you guys make where does make of
the obsession with post apocalyptic
stuff I love it like I love talking
about robots coming to get us and
zombies coming to get us and all this up
what do you think the human fascination
with like our own destruction is all
about you will hear you're into this
like whole AI kick and like how are
probably already in a computer
simulation yeah I me like that well that
has happen
I think we'll save that for another show
ma yeah but i think that people are
because Molly always kicks me on the
table and I start trading my day I but
you know I think that people always want
to know how they're gonna die right and
this is the way that you can do it is to
be obsessed right it's going to be an
asteroid or it's going to be computers
or you know is gonna be zombies so do
either of you have any hunches about how
you're gonna die I just hope it's not on
this show yeah alien acknowledges that
Haley innovation I feel like alien
invasion would be a good one good yeah
what about you um I know for certain
it's not in a plane crash which is the
only reason I don't like get terrified
every time I have to play but no I think
it's gonna be old age oh they're like
slowly croak that's sort of how you want
to do it my final thought on this help
repair do you guys for an actual
disaster forget let's pretend the
zombies and the aliens aren't cut off
but you factor that into your life like
I'm big on like I like having a lot of
water yeah I think I have a shitload of
tuna like if it goes down I'm gonna die
of mercury poisoning that's how it big
yeah I think about earthquakes all the
time being in Southern California I'll
be like lying in battle back if an
earthquake happened right now which
doorway would I run to and like was the
training I received an elementary school
sufficient to survive it yeah to that
why not yeah but I really just think
about like surviving the initial shock
of that and not really what I'm gonna do
after I feel like I'm self-sufficient I
figure it out but maybe I should be
thinking more about water and we have
stockpiles of we have a moat we have our
motorcycle downstairs to be honest which
is like also the way you get out of the
city if there's an Earthquaker so we're
prepared I like how you've prepared this
place for zombies and also a quick
escape yeah and there's a motorcycle is
about 30 of it there's a bottle of
whiskey somewhere too which is really
all using part of why we move to the
office away from the beaches in case of
a tsunami so now we're a couple miles
off last place we would have in squirt
ready are you in a zombie proof bunker
like you have your whiskey and
motorcycle ready let us know in the
comments right now